i have something for you
you said you wanted a cross and this is
the one i used to wear when i was your
age
it's so pretty i'm glad you like it
it's a nice reminder that wherever you
are
god is always with you
and it means a lot to me that you want
to wear it
thanks mom i'm going to pray right now
god it's missy again if you can hear me
better it's because i'm wearing a cross
now
please let me get a lot of hits on
saturday and if their star pitcher
breaks his arm or gets run over by a
truck
i'd totally be okay with that amen
amen then i hit it over the right
feeler's head
sounds like you had a good practice i
did coach said he's gonna have me hit
clean up
missy will you rub your cross on my bat
no have you been doing that on mine it's
working great
please i'll give you a dollar
fine what do you think you're doing
sharing god's love
making some cash absolutely not how
about i give you the dollar
god's love has nothing to do with money
what about the collection plate at
church
that is different that's where i found
this dollar
oh come here bye
are you mad at me no
you sure cause that's how you look when
dad had that breakfast beer
to be honest i'm a little concerned that
i've given you the wrong impression
about how prayer works
i get it i ask god for stuff he gives it
to me it's not rocket science
missy god does not grant wishes
so he gave me good luck it's not luck
luck is chance and god has a plan
right and his plan is to give me what i
want when i pray
that's why he's so cool no i i mean he
is cool
but sometimes that might not be his plan
and what's the point of praying if he's
just gonna do what he wants
you don't pray to god to get things you
pray
to build a relationship with him
this is too complicated i'm just gonna
keep wrapping this thing on my back
kicking butt
okay matt is it take it off no i need it
the game's saturday
there are more important things than
baseball now hand it over
god cover your ears damn it
missy cooper you are not ready for that
you give that back
oh you yet
[Music]
lord i really need you right now
i have tried so hard to lead my family
to your life
but so far sheldon doesn't believe in
you
missy thinks you're a magic trick and
you're not a teenage girl so
georgie doesn't think about you at all i
never thought i'd take across away from
my own child
but what choice did i have she was
rubbing it on sporting equipment
i didn't think there was a wrong way to
pray but leave it to that girl to find
one
please give me the strength to keep god
in my family to you
i can't do it on my own amen
[Music]
it